[Music]
I'm the chief architect at Etsy and
we're here to talk about Etsy's
migration to Google cloud awesome thanks
my name is dani rosen i am the technical
program manager at Google I worked with
Etsy on the cloud migration we're really
excited to talk to you about today so a
quick introduction to what is Etsy Etsy
is the world's largest marketplace for a
unique and creative goods we have a
community that is over 2 million sellers
39 million buyers and we have 50 million
items for sale on the site
we're also heavily like diverse 30% of
our engineers of women 4 or 6 execs are
women and we have gender parity on the
board a lot of the Etsy sellers are also
women for the vast majority of them Etsy
is their only source of income and their
businesses of one so we take all of that
into account as we make decisions for
like the company thank you so a little
bit of background about Etsy FC was
founded in 2015
sorry in 2005 this was a time that the
cloud did not exist as a concept we were
solely in the data center and that in
that time an era like we had to build a
lot of our own tech because they were
not there was not much out there that we
could use you may have heard of a little
demon called stats T that was originally
written by F see we have a bunch of CIC
retooling that we've open-source like
deploy nater
and we have a fairly popular like
programming and engineering blog at
coders cross comm the sort of the reason
that I bring that up is that we used to
be data center focused you may have you
probably like people who've worked in
the data center know this time line you
budget three to six months out you order
Hardware it takes some time to come in
then you receive it you rack and stack
it then you provision it you to set up
all the software that you need on it
before it can finally enter production
the timeline is really long and Etsy was
finding that like this workflow was not
scaling as the site was growing
and primarily like this is the these are
like the three main benefits of the
cloud like there is compute capacity
elasticity and efficiency Etsy is trying
like the 50 million items that we showed
are completely unique like they're not
SKUs that we can easily search so we
needed a lot of compute in order to
apply machine learning to figure out for
example what are the items to show to
our sellers what would be the most
compelling to them and this is like this
was really hard to do it correctly and
at scale and with some inefficiency in
the data center in Google cloud like we
can or in a cloud environment we can
spin up nodes really quickly without
having to spend upfront in like
purchasing the nodes and getting them
ready to go and the other thing is
efficiency like for Etsy the traffic
follows a sort of pattern that speaks in
the day and then slows down at night we
are burning a lot of compute like
keeping those boxes running 24 by 7 in
the data center in a cloud environment
again like this is not a problem when we
don't need the nodes we turn them off
it's efficient both from a cost
perspective and also an environmental
perspective so why Google Cloud it's a
good question why Google cloud indeed so
I think there are our four major aspects
of why Etsy chose Google cloud the first
is culture Google's culture and Etsy's
culture follow really interesting
connectivity that we're going to talk
about in a sec the second is there's a
focus on ml and that if you haven't
figured that out already as part of our
marketing narrative it's really clear in
the products that were pushing out and
how Etsy is implementing it's pretty
interesting
finally a second a third international
data centers there's a long list of data
centers we support and it works for
Etsy's global footprint and then finally
we both have a really strong commitment
to sustainability making sure that we're
taking care of the earth together and
making the right decisions for ourselves
so we say culture and what does that
actually mean on the board we have two
different articles the first is straight
out of the sre book about post-mortem
culture right this idea of being
blameless while ago a person named John
all spell from Etsy actually wrote one
of the major pieces of this in code is
Kraft that's referencing
and when you look at blameless and
postmortem culture you ask yourself well
what's the big deal why is this
important and it's about iterative
learning right it's about hey we made a
mistake and that's okay because we're
thinking for the long-term as a
collective rather than for the
short-term for somebody to blame the
next thing is machine learning right so
like finding the right crocheted octopus
on Etsy kind of hard how are you getting
better is she learning pretty clear
notably there are four thousand four
hundred and forty four crocheted
octopuses on Etsy calm totally not
kidding this is not an edit like feel
free yeah so so like if you need a
crochet octopus this is where you go um
but Etsy's search engineering team also
represented the room today is actively
looking at different ways of providing
good search results that are relevant to
queries that users are putting in so
searching for the word couch really
brings up a couch not a pillow of a
couch that's the idea next thing is
international data centers right and
there's so so many on the board and
maybe one day a whole lot more as we
grow but this is its falls the lines
with Etsy's global plans Google's plans
of expanding and having good partners
that are tech centric and building out
in these different locations and then
finally you know I think the thing that
like is is a little more emotional but
is relevant right like I have a family
and I'd like that family to grow one day
and and to persist and if we take care
of the earth and we're doing the right
thing sustainably with these big data
centers using a ton of power then like
we're gonna make sure that my family
your family are gonna have a better
place to live in and I think that you
know as a community in tech as we grow
you know the thing that at the end of
the day we're using is power we do so
sustainably and we think about the
broader ecosystem so that's why Google
let's talk a bit about how we made this
work in the partnership between the two
teams so it began in December of 2017
like in New York City in Eric Schmidt's
like side office there was a business
conversation between lawyers salespeople
talking about like how are we gonna make
this work what's the contract look like
and I'm sitting there like chewing on my
fingernails like oh I don't know right
like and and the right people in the
room we're answering the right questions
and we made it work
we start our partnership on that day in
December
weeks later suddenly I find myself
embedded as part of that C's team in
their slack answering questions talking
about different technical approaches to
building things out and actually working
out of their Brooklyn office once a week
notably Etsy has probably the best
coffee in Brooklyn hands down so from
there you know we start to understand
some of the challenges or problems as
I'm embedded I become part of the polka
the culture and we start doing
hackathons one of the teams was blocked
on some deeper details of kubernetes and
we were able to say okay let's bring you
into a Google office get some google
subject-matter experts on the floor with
you and actually do a kubernetes
hackathon and in doing so we unblocked
the tremendous amount of work from their
backlog that they had concerns about
because they simply didn't have the the
background or experience so we're able
to knock that out right away there are
some other really interesting notable
things like Seth Varga who's one of our
developer advocates did a Tech Talk on
terraform and he did it at Etsy and it
was so well done that it is now
literally a piece of Etsy's onboarding
education for their new engineers so
that they know how to use terraform
there's a Q&A session chef came and
really provided a tremendous amount of
like assistance in depth because chef
used to worship
petrichor hatchery court yeah and then
finally we did a lot of engineering and
organizational cultural alignment so I
mean like the cultures our tech
companies like at the end of the day we
like technology we like building
solutions me like figuring out the right
problems so there's a lot of good
alignment there so like Danny said
signed the contract in December of 2017
and we had a sort of hard deadline for
shutting down our data centers about 20
months away this was more or less like a
leadership decision we did not want to
pay like we'd signed to commit with
Google we had a data center footprint
and we want did not want to like have an
extremely long migration where we're
paying for two things and sort of doing
things slowly and iteratively over ten
years
we felt that we could move a little bit
faster and you will I'll explain more of
that as we go through the talk so we
essentially like tried 20 months but
four of those 20 months were like the
busy are the busiest period of Etsy like
it's the holiday season
let's see the shopping platform and that
is like our biggest quarter we try not
to make a large infrastructure will
changes then just to avoid instability
for our users so preferably like we
would prefer that the large portion of
the migration finish in the first eight
months so that we have the other eight
months as like a fallback in case we
need to fix some things or have a
complete do-over even so just to remind
you of the GAR of the ground rules that
we set for ourselves no large
architectural changes this is primarily
because we felt that doing a rewrite
would add a tremendous amount of risk to
the project let's see like I said before
has been around since 2005 the code
bases has a lot of like kinks in it it's
its legacy if you will if you would be
okay calling that and we did not feel
that we had like the time to sort of
rewrite it into a sort of microservices
architecture in the way in a way that
would make it like that would stick with
our timelines the other thing was to
migrate the fewer systems needed like
Etsy has been around for many years we
have lots of systems a lot of supporting
systems and we wanted to see what is the
minimum set of systems that we can
migrate in order to run etsy.com in GCP
and thirdly like to stay compliant like
we're a public company we had to comply
with a set of regulations and rules that
we could not sort of break so this is
roughly like the timeline that we came
up with so at the partnership set up a
squad do like do all the work to get
there and then cut over by August and
then do some tuning if everything goes
smoothly then like by the time like
Thanksgiving hits the site is running in
TCP and is completely stable so Danny
briefly touched on the partnership
aspect so I'm just gonna skip forward to
the migration so Etsy is infrastructure
is made up of a bunch of teams like they
own their own systems their own roadmaps
and their own tools and this creates a
problem for a project as complicated as
a migration because the migration throws
a wrench into everyone's plans we did
not want to disrupt all of these teams
from doing what they were doing which
really mission-critical stuff for
etsy.com so instead what we came up with
was a migration squad we took one or
more people from every one of those
teams we took away all of their other
responsibilities and focused them solely
on this task of moving etsy.com to the
cloud this allowed them to basically
like not get distracted by day-to-day
stuff like etsy.com was still running in
the data center which meant that there
were still things that needed to be
fixed
issues that came up site outages and
stuff like that but they did not have to
focus on any of those things they were
solely working on the migration so once
we have the squad setup we had to figure
out how to work with like the tools in
the cloud Etsy as I'd alluded to before
had a bunch of custom in-house tooling
to manage things in the data center for
example to provision a box like we
rewrote our own tools it is open sourced
but it was written by us to manage their
sort of various permutations and
combinations of hardware in Google Cloud
this was not a problem like we had to
pick a tool we picked error form but we
had to learn how to use it
Google was again a great partner like
set Wargo came on board taught us a lot
about how to correctly do terraform at
scale but it was something that we had
to learn and figure out another example
of this would be like learning how to
use stackdriver or learning the sort of
ins and outs of the Google Network if
you will so just to segue a little bit
into the Etsy architecture server we've
been around for a long time where a lamp
stack that was the hardest thing to do
in 2005 Linux Apache PHP my sequel and
because we might have been around for so
long like we have a giant monolith it's
held together by our monolithic shards
and then memcache is our primary caching
tier and the code is all sorts of
tangles which are really hard to figure
out and sometimes like causes some
issues but the good thing about the se
architecture is that the system's
diagram is relatively straightforward
there is a load balancer up front that
serves requests for like that
processes the first that is the first
stop in a request to etsy.com there are
some web servers that feel the request
they further talk to some web servers
hidden behind some internal load
balancers eventually talking to a
database this is an architecture that we
were able to reason about really well
about the performance characteristics
the sort of what what could go wrong a
pre-mortem was like really easy or
relatively easy to do with this kind of
architecture that we had thing over time
that has been happening at Etsy as we've
been also doing API first development
where like I said before where PHP site
so we don't really have the idea of an
event loop but we've emulated that by
using curl so let me quickly explain how
that works so this is like if you think
of the etsy.com homepage there's a bunch
of modules on it so like a favorites
module a friend's activity or Etsy blog
content or promotions or personalized
content for you so when you land on
etsy.com it actually splits up
internally into four requests for all of
the different modules that I described
which may further break up into more
requests to actually fetch the data from
the cache or a database and all of these
are API tiers that are hidden away the
sort of nice aspect of this is it allows
us to scale the system at every single
layer without affecting the other layers
so like every single one of these is a
web server and a load balancer so we're
able to scale up and down as we need and
sort of reason about the system without
needing to understand the full picture
or having to worry about dependencies or
sort of tangled a sort of tangled tree
of code so how on earth do we like
migrate this thing to Google Cloud just
to quickly reiterate these were sort of
our goals and the way that we like
talked about it internally was like
maybe we can set up some read replicas
etsy.com simple application why wouldn't
it read replica work so this is like we
discussed this internally for a very
long time but it came down to the fact
that because of our mana
like shards like we could not we've come
to rely on some behaviors like
immediately read after right consistency
this would be really hard to replicate
if we were to spin up replicas of our
data center set up in GCP that would be
you know many tens of milliseconds away
from the data center which would mean
that the consistency would not be
accurate to within a millisecond or even
within a single transaction another
thing that we discussed was to maybe
spin up active active so keep one copy
of etsy.com running in the data center
and then spin up a completely active
copy in GCP in multiple regions and
redirect traffic maybe over like geoip
by based on where the user is coming
from but again the monolith and the sort
of tangled dependencies made this really
hard for us to do without having to do a
rewrite and one of our key goals was to
not do a rewrite of the application so
what we ended up doing or what we landed
on was a sort of lift and shift as I had
said before like the application we felt
we could reason about reasonably well so
a lift and shift was actually a
perfectly reasonable approach for where
we were in time remember we only had 20
months to migrate and our application
was a monolith that we did not feel we
could rewrite in that period but the
problem with the lift and shift was that
we there was there is no clean way to
switch traffic over if you had an active
active copy you could sort of bring all
of them up and then turn one of them
down no one would notice but with the
lifted shift that was really not an
option so we instead proactively
communicated with our sellers that were
gonna take a maintenance window the site
will be unavailable for a portion of
time while we sort of migrated to Google
cloud and brought it up there this is
not again anyone's first preferred
approach but we felt that given the
constraints that we were under and the
basically time system limitations that
this was the best approach for Etsy and
being proactive with our sellers meant
that we did not necessarily cost him any
surprise like we didn't just go down we
gave them enough notice that this was
going to happen so they were able to
plan for it so once we got all of the
tooling
once we got comfortable with all of the
tooling and sort of getting things spun
up in the cloud
we entered the functional testing and
the load and performance testing phase
so etsy.com is a website driven
primarily by like to load in the holiday
season so we have some expectations
about that load we made sure to test for
at least 2x the traffic mgcp once we had
all of the systems up and running and
basically like even if you're in the
cloud like things that you focus on in
the data center still matter
for example CP architectures like in the
DC all of our boxes were really custom
we had them tuned really well for our
workload and we found that we had to do
some of that in GCP as well like GCP
offers at least at the time three
classes of hardware three classes of cpu
hardware and we found that skylake was
the most performant for us but it was
not the default in the region that we
were in so as we did load and
performance testing we found this what
we were again able to tune it with
terraform to always pick the one that we
needed and was a pretty decent like 10%
win in in load I'm sorry the capacity
for us and at scale even 99.9 percent
might not be enough so the Google global
load balancer at that time had a bug
where an extremely long tail of requests
the latency would spike a lot because of
some discovery Google was a fantastic
partner for who worked with us on this
like we've told them we had an issue
they engaged us they set up all of the
packet captures at the various levels of
the hypervisor to figure this bug out
and fixed it but this was again like a
thing that was a learning curve for Etsy
like we were always in the data center
we knew we owned everything so once the
requests entered our network we had full
control and this was something that we
had to adjust to like if there's an
issue how do you work with your partner
to figure out what the issue is and how
do you remediate that so a quick sort of
segue into the most amazing outage
probably of my career so while we were
setting up Google Cloud
and parallel infrastructure in Google
cloud to do so to do all of this testing
we had staged the IP in preparation for
the car over the way that we had done it
was we have two DNS providers one of
them supports I do not surf like
basically what that means has never
served this DNS record no matter what
but the other DNS provider did not
support I do not surf flag so we instead
we added it on into the provider with a
load of 0 with a ratio of 0 what 0 means
is run health checks and if the other
site is if the other IP address is down
then you're okay serving this record as
it happens after we had done this
etsy.com
had a small orig for about 10 minutes
the main site was done because we did we
were doing something it didn't work but
what happened was we served the GCP test
infrastructure IP to our customers
because the good thing was that that
infrastructure was not scaled to handle
traffic at the rate at which the traffic
had landed so it immediately fell over
but for a few of our customers they saw
a slightly unusual experience like the
colors were all wrong because we were
using blue to signify that this is a
test infrastructure not orange the SE
orange so it was a little it was not
like it was it caused some some emails
to our support site but in like true
Etsy fashion like we celebrated this
outage like it was completely unexpected
behavior for everyone involved
and the engineer like who was most
proximate to it won the etsy is covered
at 3m Federer Ward for causing the most
spectacular outage of the year
so moving on on the timeline finally
coming to the actual car over we did all
of the testing functional testing load
testing in order to gain confidence and
we realized that the only way that we
would know if this would truly work was
to send live traffic at it no amount of
testing can mimic the complexity of
production and the SC app is complex
enough that we could not cover every
single thing through simulation so we
felt that we had to at least cut over
once
to learn more about where the heart what
are the hardest problems here that we
have not found through like basically
that our engineers may not even be aware
of so the way that we planned for it was
to have a soft phrase like this was a
new thing for Etsy like we are a
continuous deployment shop we deploy 30
times a day but in preparation for
cutover we were we communicated to all
of our engineers that like for a couple
of days like things will be moving
slower so it would be a soft freeze
we're only p1 but 6 this would go out
and then we would enter a full freeze
where no changes except those required
to basically set up just Cod over for
success would be allowed and then there
would be a sort of period of heightened
on-call monitoring a lot of teams had
signed up for rotations so that they
would help them serve the site once we
were running in GCP yeah that was all as
he's approach to the cut over process a
pretty different one Google also had an
approach so I think the important
context here is that at sea ran their
own data centers everything in their
data centers so if any network issues
happened they had network engineers that
knew what was going on
now Etsy is taking the responsibility of
effectively running their data centers
and giving it to Google that's scary so
what we did to support them is we went
in and masqueraded effectively as that's
the engineers and we went through a
two-week immersed training in Etsy
myself and a couple of other Googlers
went in and then said ok we understand
the lay of the land how the systems work
we provided what we're just calling
artifacts right we actually created
system overviews product overviews and
gave that to our support teams that they
had context on what to know if Etsy
called and something was broken
specifically for cutover but hey even
after they still have these artifacts so
they have some system archaeology and
knowledge of state another thing that's
important here is that as he has an
interesting engineering culture and Etsy
in terms right and every company has
corp speak so we've got that down to you
in a glossary so that's kind of one part
of the work we did the other part was we
created what we'll call the war room
which basically was a cut over a day
team approach to connecting the Etsy
team us who are actually on site at 3:00
in the morning and the support teams
that were monitoring a couple days
before myself a couple of others run a
gigantic email thread to hundreds of
Googlers saying SC is going live this
weekend at 3:00 a.m. effectively be
ready as sorry teams or product teams
are engineering teams all pretty much
had an awareness of the situation and
and you know we did it we basically we
got on site we came in numbers there
were three of us and it was 3:00 in the
morning and we worked together to start
the cutover process probably one of the
most important factors here was that we
had donuts in having donuts we were able
to energize the team so I wanted to
thank specifically the sales team at
Google for providing the donuts thanks
guys cool so cutover day they picked a
Sunday morning it was 3:00 a.m. it was
the we determined that this was the
lowest traffic type of the week for us
it would be the least impactful to do a
cut over at this time because we had
planned on being done for about four
hours
so the rough idea was start at 3 a.m.
turn affects e-comm in the data center
do some validation and testing in GCP on
the infra that we have there and then
slowly ramp up traffic to GCP and then
make a decision about whether to stay or
not
as you can imagine like turning off
website is not trivial
so etsy.com had been has been like a
continuously operated site for many
years and there were there are a lot of
systems that are always running to make
everything smooth so like offline
processing jobs asynchronous jobs big
data jobs database backups all of these
things that we had to plan for and
execute in a particular like in a exact
series of steps in order to do it safely
because we obviously did not want to
lose any of our customer information nor
did we want our customers to see
vere behavior on the site so the way
that we did it we blot them off at the
Sirian layer so that everyone who's
coming sees a uniform
experience that the s site is done for
maintenance and then we work with our
databases with our Libya is an other
essary
it shows to like make sure that
everything turns off in just the right
order and we did this like it took us
about an hour and a half exactly what
we'd planned for but the site was done
correctly and was replicate and all of
the data more importantly was replicated
to GCP so that we could bring the site
back up in GCP so around 4:30 a.m. we
did a cut over like the site was running
in TCP but only for internal users only
for all of our engineers who were there
for to test and as these things happen
we ran into something that we had never
run into testing we ran out of memory on
some key systems that only run on some
key offline processing systems that we
had not specifically tested but they
were important enough as we found during
the cutover that we could not basically
launch to our real users we it was also
like 4:30 in the morning everyone no one
had slept for the night everyone was
really groggy and we felt that we could
not figure this out in time to make our
window so unfortunately we rolled back
but this was good from like the way that
we approached the problem because we
discovered something new we discovered
that we had not covered in enough detail
an area of the site that we needed to do
better in order to try this again and
why did we have to try again because of
this like we had eight months to do this
right we were already in August and if
we didn't do it in August then we would
have to wait four months until January
before we were able to have another shot
at this so we felt like that if we were
able to address the problems that we saw
and we needed to try again at least once
so that all of the people who had worked
really hard like their work would pay
off without having to wait for ten
months those end months could mean many
different things like code would have
changed in that time infrastructure in
the data center would have drifted in
that time and we would have had to sort
of redo a whole bunch of things if we
waited that long so after like fixing
and doing a bunch more testing we
decided to give ourselves another shot
at the car over
made a couple of changes we decided to
start earlier in the night so start at
1:00 a.m. and we gave ourselves a
six-hour window to do the migration
rather than the four R's from last time
we felt that this added enough buffer
that if we ran into issues that we would
be able to fix them so we turned off
etsy.com we had gotten really good at
this at this point having done it twice
like once off and then once on again and
we ended up finding new errors in the
validation and testing phase as an
example run some demons that had too few
threads and this was causing some
backups some delays in critical
operations we fix that in another case
we had too many threads and this was
again causing system instability but
because we had set ourselves enough time
we were able to find and remediate these
on the spot and finally like this time
around we were able to ramp up real
users to the site so around like 5:30
a.m. real users in the slow trickle
started to see etsy.com work in GCP at
which point became like after we had
been running in TCP for a few hours like
this was sort of a key decision which is
should we stay we were learning new
things as Alex showing some slides that
follow but do we stay or do we roll back
like are things good enough that we can
stay here and continue to learn or are
they not good enough on some axes that
we need to roll back the axes that we
had set for ourselves were operational
stability whether it was burning out our
ops teams or is it impacting our sails
too much in a way that we can measure or
is the performance on GCP not that great
the performance one was is interesting
because like I had said before in my
talk like in our data center everything
was really tuned for optimal performance
like we had we had the exact set of
hardware that would give us the best
performance for our data bases for our
memcache is for our web servers and in
GCP it is less of like there is less
variability like you only have a certain
class of boxes and certain classes of
CPUs and we felt like we did a lot of
synthetic testing but that can never
capture the complexity of fraud we only
covered 80
of the traffic and the other 20% the
longtail we had no idea or we had some
idea but not an exact idea of how that
would perform so it was like a big
variable for us but we found that the
performance is actually quite all right
so all the way on the right is
performance in GCP the two black black
spots in the middle are two cutover
windows but as you can see the perf was
not that bad like it was within bounce
that we had set ourselves that this
would be okay and we can tolerate this
and we can make this better over time
but we need to like we'll continue
running in GCP so now we entered the
sort of tuning phase before like the big
Black Friday Cyber Monday there was a
ton of things that we were discovering
in in GCP in production so optimizing
system calls GCP and an any cloud
provider is a massively virtualized
environment in the data center we were
running on bare metal we found that if
we optimized away some system calls like
it would make our performance on some
key systems really predictable like
really smooth and not as jagged so we
did that
the other key win for us was my sequel
in GCP had some really unusual behavior
on mutexes which was only visible when
there was sufficient amount of read and
write traffic to this that we were
simply unable to replicate through
synthetic testing but the showed up in
production and we worked with Google
engineers and internal and like DBAs and
other systems minded folks to figure
this out and fix it like adjusting
kernel parameters and my sequel
variables the other thing is again the
network showed up as a huge factor like
Google's network is a software-defined
network it is not routers and switches
in the way that it would be in a data
center and at extremely large
percentiles 99.999% if you do it law if
you do often it often enough and at
scale then those network jitter /
variances really matters so in the case
of memcache for example which we use
really heavily we found that the latency
is would spike from a few
like microseconds too many hundreds of
milliseconds and this would matter for
our application this was another thing
that we just had to go to Prague to
discover because we were like the sort
of request patterns that prod has we
were was really hard to mimic in a test
environment in a simulation but this was
again like Google will great partners
with us like they did they engaged them
they did all the packet captures they
figured out what was the issue over some
period of time and they fixed it it was
actually a bug in their sdn that we
found for them Thanks so like this was
roughly the timeline like we got through
all the tuning phase and we made it to
Cyber Monday without any issues like we
survived in slush more than survived
like we were able to scale up and down
during cyber monday as we needed to in
order to like manage all of our load all
of the load that was on the site and it
worked out like the way that we had
hoped so some observations from being in
the cloud like we've been running in the
cloud for about 7 months now and we've
learned some things so long live flows
in the data center again like this was
something that we did not have to care
about if service opened a connection to
another service it could go on for weeks
hours months and it would not matter but
then Google software-defined network
this was a problem a connection can only
be idle for 10 minutes before the SDN
kills it this was something that we had
to discover the hard way where we had a
bunch of services that were acting
weirdly but it was something that we
could adopt to like using keep our lives
or using things allowed us to work
around this but this was a thing that we
had to learn and all of the service
owners had to adopt specifically to the
other like on the plus side lie
migrations really good in if Google who
needs to do migrate to it needs to do
maintenance on a host they will live
migrate you off to another host and this
works even at for like things like
memcache and my sequel which have large
memory pools
and a lot of traffic and the blip is
really tiny so like this is something
that would be like made our made our
jobs really easy from an operational
perspective and lastly infinite capacity
the cloud promises to be infinite but at
scale it really is not yes are you doing
Danny so I can speak to that so so I
think I think that's part of the
narrative of cloud right we just I can
just burst and I have all this capacity
and everything I need and all the CPUs I
need another Ram and everything is there
for me right so that's that's that's the
cloud vision all right
so and that works by the way if you want
like 500 chorus sounds good you want
more having a chorus 700 course a
thousand course go for it but when you
want 50,000 course and you want it now
it's a little different and I think when
we start thinking about that there's a
there's two layers right the first is
people right we want to give you all the
capacity we can do just to support your
activities but there are many other
people who also want 50,000 cores of the
same thing that you might so thinking
about that idea you start to realize
that how it's not just 50,000 for me
it's 50,000 for lots of other large
customers and then also it's kind of
reasonable to say that hardware is still
thing that we need to buy and put in our
data centers and that takes time that
was outlined here too right at the end
of the day cloud is just somebody else's
computer we need more computers so
infinite capacity makes sense
but at the right scale rather than at a
massive one and like we like Danny and
others other Googlers were like good
partners to help us figure out like how
much heads up do we need to give them if
we needed 50,000 course we needed them
so this was something that we had to
learn like me where our cycle was a year
before now was it was much smaller like
we could give them heads of maybe a
month in advance and we would have the
hardware rather than 12 months in
advance as it was before so coming to an
end
circles of success yeah so I think we
added this slide in because we wanted to
call out I think one of the fundamental
factors of a large-scale migration of a
system like this that it takes a village
so there were Googlers a tremendous
amount of Googlers who put in
their time and effort to make sure this
happened and it happened pretty
seamlessly not just for Google but
really for Etsy and Etsy's customers and
there's the Etsy ins now it's kind of
interesting is you really had these
three circles and I'll beat this to
Chris who's in the front row here he
came up with this idea which was there
are three circles of kind of influence
or ownership or impact we'll call three
circles of impact in Etsy the first is
kind of your core team right this is
your your squad not only are these
people there to develop the systems and
the ideas around them but they're also
on call right because they have the
deepest context so that's the first kind
of core that's like maybe five seven
people or so and then outside of that as
Kara mentioned you had a team of people
who are testing the site like going to
Etsy calm when it was live at 4:00 in
the morning and making sure that the
manual testing covered all the edge
cases and use cases they didn't think of
in the first place right these people
are giving up a lot of time they're
coming up run books beforehand and
they're there to help and make an impact
this is kind of another layer and then
finally outside of that you have this
broad layer of people in the
organization that supported everyone had
management you had teammates who took on
work that other folks would say hey
listen I can't do this because I'm on
the squad can you help me out you know
even people in security who are on the
outside actually letting people into the
building at 3:00 a.m. like like it takes
a village and I think it's worth saying
that and acknowledging that you know a
cloud migration really any systems
migration it's a cloud is is best done
as a team and notably value should be
attributed to the people who did that
right so even the security person who
woke up it's 2:30 in the morning to get
to the Brooklyn office should be given
credit because he was there also to make
that happen
all right so as like I said of speaking
before they did a lifted shift but it is
not where we want to end up
we did a lifted shift for a bunch of
reasons which was to move fast and to
move with confidence and to introduce
less risk into what was already a fairly
complex migration but they're not like
we don't want to rest on our laurels we
don't want to stay there we want to make
things better so we want to be
refactoring our monolith to fit better
in the cloud to use like cloud native
technologies we also want to get a good
handle on like cost management being in
the data center
cost equation was relatively
straightforward it was you buy some
hardware and then you use it for three
years or you don't use it but it doesn't
matter there is an GCP like it really
matters if the box is up and running and
you're not using it and we have a lot of
technical debt that we need to pay down
like not a lot of it I mean some of it
added because of the migration but some
of it that existed way before that we
feel that we can now pay down much more
effectively for example like if we
wanted to spin up new servers in the
data center we would have to follow the
usual waterfall model of like placing
those orders early enough so that we
were able to have the capacity needed to
affect any kind of refactoring in GCP
it's a lot more straightforward you spin
up some Terra firme config as long as
Google has the heads up about the
capacity that we need it's there and
we're able to like execute and iterate
much more quickly and with less bayless
friction and we want to also look at our
org structures where like running in the
cloud SRE is the thing that we want to
adopt the practices around it around
building reliable systems in the cloud
that we did not necessarily need to
focus on when we were in the data center
so some of the things that SC is working
on another positive
[Music]